je demande c'est squeeze et comme vous
pouvez voir j'ai déménagé et oui vous
vous embêter les couleurs allez on y va
c'est un vrai katana dallaire toi si oui
comment tu l'as eu parce que oui dont
christiane times épisode 1 il y avait un
katana derrière moi alors oui c'est un
vrai katana et comment je les ai eus
comme ça bonjour revendre et des katanas
non parce qu en fait j'aimerais tué
quelqu'un
j'aimerais lui couper la tête voilà
gagner la taille de ton pénis
lol est ce que tu aimes les décors
magiques qui volent et qui font des
croûtes arc en ciel est bien à vrai dire
j'ai jamais vus de luxe aux [ __ ]
qu'est ce qu'elles sont belles pourquoi
le nom squeeze alors vous allez bien
vous [ __ ] de ma gueule mais l'histoire
de mon pseudo se résume à ça mais
comment ils font les gens pour trouver
leur pseudo sérieux bond à temps c'est
quoi titre de la musique que j'écoute
squeeze tu twittes n'enseignera with it
non c'est de la merde rageux c'est ce
quiz et quelle note as-tu pris au bac
alors ça c'est une excellente question
je me souviendrai toujours de ce jour là
alors le cas où il est oui c'est moi
c'est à vous tirer un papier au hasard
oh [ __ ] j'ai tiré un trait
[Applaudissements]
ce métier pex il ya écrit chicane ce
quiz fois-ci danse absolument pas le
chèque ça veut dire secoué et squeeze ça
veut dire prêt c'est donc ce quiz vous y
voilà ça se ressent mais c'est pour ça
qu'il ya marqué ce coup sûr une tipp ex
c'est parce qu'il faut presser regardez
bien la main de son frère elle est une
bague et une somme que l'on sait
vraiment offre deux fois que cette
question et bien voici l'explication en
5 secondes
parce que je vous aime
c'était le nouveau tube de florent
intitulé j'ai les onglons déjà
disponible sur itunes donnerais-tu la
vie de gwen pour sauver le monde
what the fuck mais qu'est ce que c'est
que cette question et ce n'est dans un
cours de philosophie actuellement dans
un monde où la thérapie est insuffisante
que répondriez vous à la prunelle des
yeux d'un oiseau mort je répondrai la
réponse b mais oui mais c'est formidable
c'étaient les souvenirs de philo de
squeeze tu sais pas te raser la
moustache
[Musique]
oui ce challenge est plutôt chiant et ce
qui s'est passé et enfin casse quelque
chose je peux plus être au plaza c'était
un trop long à ces conneries y ait un
deux trois et quatre explosions
au tabac
vous voilà face à b nous avons aussi
l'épreuve du bac temps bon du pss
histoire mais free camaro gt n'a pas
disparu elle des mongoliens le seul flux
de bp
je vais me tourner dans l'olivier à
hollywood thomas mich